[Music]
on this Tuesday night Israel bombs a
refugee camp in
Gaza the Carnage and Israel's claim it
killed a top Hamas Commander plus fresh
warnings about what civilians are
enduring Gaza has become a graveyard for
children it's a living hell for everyone
else no longer gun shy I need something
to protect myself and my family Israel's
government makes it easier for civilians
to buy firearms cada's plan to handle
record levels of immigration and
concerns about where those people will
live plus feeling sour not as many bags
and the bags are smaller the foul flavor
of inflation haunting Halloween candy
Shoppers global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us Israel's Army does not call
its assault on Gaza and Invasion but for
a fifth night it certainly looks that
way its soldiers and tanks are advancing
on the ground and its war planes
pounding targets from the air these vast
craters are from Israeli air strikes on
a refugee camp the IDF claims it was
targeting tunnels beneath it and that it
killed a top Hamas Commander dozens of
bodies were taken to hospital Israel
says if civilians are killed it's
because Hamas is using them as human
Shields there are Fierce battles the IDE
F says and these two Israeli soldiers
are the first to be killed in them both
of them are 20 years old it is
impossible to get precise information
about what's happening in Gaza no one
can get in or out and very little
information can be independently
verified our coverage begins with Mike
Armstrong in Jerusalem and a warning
some of the details in his story may be
disturbing it is a conflict being fought
with weapons and cameras both sides are
releasing images of their troops in
action this is video released Tuesday by
the Israeli Defense
Forces and this is video released by
Hamas it shows Fighters appearing to
come out of a tunnel and engaging IDF
soldiers it was shot in the northeast
corner of Gaza when hasn't been
independently
verified now there is also video
released by a hospital this is from the
Facebook page of Gaza City Indonesian
Hospital showing an emergency room
overwhelmed the scene outside horrific
dozens of bodies lined against the wall
according to the hospital after air
strikes on the jabalia refugee
camp we have no idea what to do this
doctor says there are injured
everywhere video from the camp shows two
craters and people being pulled from the
rubble the Hamas run Health Ministry
says more than than 150 people were
wounded and 50 killed the Israeli
military confirms its fighter jets
dropped bombs on the camp the spokesman
says they were targeting a senior Hamas
commander and that some of the damage
was from the collapse of hamas's
underground
infrastructure now bombings aren't the
only problem for gsin with food Fuel and
Medicine running out the United Nations
warned Tuesday of an imminent Public
Health catastrophe the UN has operating
150 Refugee centers they are at more
than triple capacity Sheltering
672 th000 people so they are wildly
overcrowded now access to water is a
major problem in some places output is
at just 5% of normal levels in others
it's out completely deaths from
dehydration the UN says are a growing
concern Gaza has become a graveyard for
children it's a living heal for everyone
else there may be hope for some of the
hostages taken by Hamas a video was
released Tuesday evening of a spokesman
for the armed wing of the group in it he
says they will in the coming Days
release some foreign captives Hamas is
not giving a number or nationalities
that spokesperson also denies by the way
that they were holding the IDF soldier
who was freed over the weekend he says
she was being held by another group
Donna my Armstrong thanks even before
the October 7th attacks by Hamas on
Israel prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
promised to make it easier for Israelis
to buy guns then last week in a national
address he encouraged civilians to arm
themselves for self-defense and many
Israelis are listening gun licenses used
to be hard to get in Israel not anymore
Danielle Hangin is looking into that
tonight Danielle Donna since October 7th
Israel has seen
150,000 new applications for gun
licenses a process that used to take
months can now be done in days the
government wants Israel's
armed this is a normal site in
Israel Firearms out in the open many not
all are off-duty soldiers
come what's unusual now is the number of
civilians who are firsttime gun
owners applications for licenses have
soared since October
7th there are Israelis from all walks of
life here who have rushed to get their
first gun and something the owners of
his shooting range had never seen before
so many
women many with husbands serving in the
military who now find themselves home
alone with their
children like Sarah I took one of the
smallest I'm a
woman a mother of four who hasn't used a
gun in 20 years not since she served in
the Army if I want the gun I need to pay
now because the the guns are running out
in you know very rapid uh very rapidly
for a long time she was reluctant to get
one but she says Everything's changed I
feel that I need something to protect
myself and my family we need to win this
war and we need to bring back uh the
security for you know we need to feel
secure in our
home there is a belief held by many that
so long as Palestinians don't have
security neither will
Israelis in East Jerusalem on Monday an
Israeli police officer was stabbed by a
Palestinian Israeli National Security
Minister itamar benav then showed up to
the
scene urging Israelis to go armed
themselves it's a message he's taken
around the country while handing out
rifles to volunteer security squads in
areas with people sympathetic to his far
right
views trainings for firsttime gun owners
used to be held three times a week here
now it's twice a day people who thought
they'd never have to hold a gun in their
lives now don't want to go anywhere in
Israel without one the US has on more
than one occasion condemned national
security minister itamar benav not just
for racist comments he's made about
Arabs but more recently for handing out
those weapons to civilians weapons
supplied by the US once's considered a
dangerous extremist he's now part of the
Coalition keeping Benjamin Netanyahu in
power Donna Danielle Hamin in Jerusalem
thanks in the US a senate hearing into
funding Israel and Ukraine was
interrupted multiple times
today protesters some with their hands
painted red shouted ceasefire and
stopped sending money to Israel they
were eventually removed the US Secretary
of State and the defense secretary were
outlining the Biden administration's
request for a $100 billion Aid package
which the White House says would go
towards support for Israel and for
Ukraine as well as security along
America's Southern Border in Canada the
the federal government has given
Atlantic Canadians a break on paying the
carbon tax on home heating oil but today
prime minister Justin Trudeau says there
will be no other exemptions as McKenzie
gray reports that doesn't mean critics
of the carbon tax are easing off on the
pressure have an exemption on that the
liberal signature climate policy will
stay intact for now there will
absolutely not be any other carve outs
or suspensions of the price on pollution
but Justin Trudeau did give out a major
car out last week exempting home heating
oil from carbon tax increases only
impacting 3% of Canadian households but
they're overwhelmingly located in the
liberal stronghold of Atlantic Canada
leaving other Premier wanting similar
rebates on natural gas and Hydra 95% of
people in Ontario do not eat their homes
or businesses with oil it's completely
unfair that they still have to pay the
carbon tax federal opposition also
calling for savings let's take the gsse
off of Home Heating that's going to
provide relief to all Canadians this is
clear not about environmental science
it's about political science and that
political science with him is always
divide and conquer divisions rejected by
East Coast liberals who lobbed Trudeau
aggressively for the suspension I just
find it a bit Rich that everybody is
just getting so excited about carve outs
and exceptions and particularities to
Regions that's how this country was
built the Atlantic assistance aided by a
program to give out free heat pumps to
low-income residents in PEI New Finland
and Nova Scotia to reduce oil
consumption home heating oil is
significantly more expensive it has
escalated significantly in the last
couple of years the significant change
to one of trudo's Legacy programs not a
concern for the Deputy Prime Minister no
we're not undermining the policy overall
this is going to accelerate the
transition and going to make life more
affordable the chrisan Freeland view was
rejected by two prominent liberals
former Bank of Canada Governor Mark
Carney and the architect of the carbon
tax Katherine McKenna both saying the
government should stick to a predictable
climate policy Donna all right McKenzie
gray in Ottawa thanks there is some
evidence Canada may now be in a
technical recession that's according to
preliminary data from stats Canada its
August GDP report shows Canada's economy
remain flat for the second consecutive
month final numbers for September aren't
out yet but preliminary estimates
suggests the flat economic Trend
continued and if that holds GDP will
have fallen for two straight quarters
that suggests a technical recession
though economists say the declines are
small and they usually look for broader
weakness to signify an actual recession
Canada's latest immigration targets will
be released tomorrow and the government
says healthc care and infrastructure
planning will all be taken into account
Canada was one of the fastest growing
countries in the world last year the new
immigration targets are not expected to
take a significant dip though as Tera
isre reports support from Canadians for
increased immigration appears to be
dwindling your Canada is sticking to its
plan to keep welcoming a record number
of immigrants we continue to have
significant demand for newcomers
especially workers who are bringing
skills we need like healthcare trades to
build new homes the country is on track
to bring in a half a million newcomers
next year to fill gaps in a labor
shortage and deal with an aging
population immigration Minister Mark
Miller will release the exact numbers
Wednesday but has already said he will
not drop levels Des despite growing
questions about where these newcomers
will live the real issue is getting our
acts together and and I think that's
forem for the people that come here this
is again an issue of failure of planning
in in terms of the the housing crunch a
new poll shows 44% of Canadians surveyed
say overall there is too much
immigration to Canada up from 27% the
previous year for the first time in many
years we have found a sharp drop in the
number of Canadians who seem comfortable
with the level of immigration the
biggest declines in support were in
British Columbia and Ontario with many
concerned there is not enough housing
there's no shift towards anti-immigrant
sentiment I think that's very important
it's really a question about the volume
and how many can we manage population
growth cannot come at all costs we need
the corresponding Investments to do it
well I swear another study from The
Institute for Canadian citizenship and
the conference Board of Canada was also
released on immigration it shows
immigrants are moving to Canada at a
record rate but a growing number are not
staying longterm because of a range of
challenges things like credential
recognition um inability to have their
professional experience recognized or to
find employment issues like housing
affordability Health Care Etc Ottawa has
pledged to better match immigrants with
the needs of Canada's labor market by
prioritizing Healthcare and construction
workers but in order to bring housing
costs down Canada needs to build more
than 3 and2 million homes by the end of
the decade teria isri Global News
Ottawa body cam footage from that August
fire in lahina
Hawaii you got to go coming up the video
just released showing Maui police on a
life-saving mission plus the BC company
converting aircraft into valuable tools
to fight Wild
fires a Canadian is reportedly among
three foreign residents who died in
Mexico when hurricane otus tore through
aapo last week Global Affairs Canada
says it is aware of the reports and is
working with local officials 47 people
are known to have died when the fast
moving hurricane hit aapa with little
warning dozens of people are still
unaccounted for 33 boats sank when the
category 5 storm slammed into the resort
City it suspected many people died when
their vessels
sank you got to
go Maui police have released this body
cam footage 16 minutes of it taken on
August 8th that's when a wildfire
devastated lahina the video shows
officers frantically banging on doors
telling anyone inside their homes to get
out at one point they Rescue an elderly
man as the fire inches closer to his
home in another clip police helped 15
people trapped inside a coffee shop that
Wildfire destroyed most of the town of
lahina killing at least 99 people
burning more than 2,000 structures the
cause of the fire is still under
investigation shifting strategy ahead of
BC company's unique approach to help the
Wildfire
fight as temperatures cool Canada's
record-breaking Wildfire season
continues to smolder as of October more
than 400 fires across Canada were still
considered active at least 100 were
listed as out of control and for some in
British Columbia that fight is shifting
their unique expertise in attacking
wildfires from the air is being sought
out by agencies around the world NE
thara
explains this was the first year that
really it was all hands- on Deck uh and
all our aircraft and all our Pilots were
uh were fighting fires all summer it's
actually dropped the reant we have a
drop button here Mark be says this has
been the busiest Wildfire season he's
ever seen in 40 years as a pilot but one
thing that's helped him manage it is
flying these new air tankers dubbed the
most modern available anywhere in the
world new AR avionics uh better
navigation systems um the airplane's
fully pressurized uh and it has has air
conditioning be and his crew support
firefighters on the ground the tanks can
carry about 10,000 L of water or
[__] to slow fires down they can
close and the tank the tanker can go
around and do another load in a
different direction another portion of
the load so not all the water has
to exactly in a process unique to Canada
BC based Conair aerial firefighting
creates these air tankers out of this
hanger in abbottford BC it's a tiny
little industry we're one of very few
companies that do this around the world
the company recently acquired seven
commercial airplanes including from
bankrupt UK air line flybe the company
then converts those former commercial
aircrafts into air tankers it was fully
loaded as a passenger aircraft so one of
the first things we do is remove the
interior full seats overhead bins
everything you'd expect to see when you
get on a commercial aircraft this will
be ready to fight fires anywhere so uh
it will be contracted um by the US
Forest Service or individual states uh
for next Fire season in 2024 about half
of conair's more than 90 pilots and
nearly 70 aircraft are now back on base
after their deployments across BC but
like this crew doing the air tanker
conversion behind me they're showing no
signs of slowing down we also have
Pilots that have deployed now to
Australia um so we have uh three
airplanes down there this winter as well
so we're really operating uh 12 months a
year now and there's all kinds of thank
you cards in our in our crew rooms and
and from the people that you know we've
saved their their houses and and they
know it they appreciate us uh when they
see us flying the company also creates
emergency response aircraft several of
which which have been purchased by the
French government and used to support
Aid efforts in the war on Ukraine our
tagline is protecting our world you know
and and that sounds yeah that sounds
simplistic but really when we when we
develop that tagline when we boil down
everything that we do it's about that
you so it's important there's a lot of
Pride behind the process of bringing
this aerial firefighting resource to
markets across the globe Nara Global
News abbottford
BC
nothing to Snicker at next the scary
rise in Halloween candy
prices tonight is Halloween and aside
from working out last minute complaints
from the kids about costumes some
parents are feeling a little spooked by
the prices as Heather urick West
explains inflation means many favorite
treats are shrinking in size and costing
[Music]
more it's the spookiest time time of the
year being ghastly is the
goal but the real chills this
Halloween is how much everything costs
do you find that you're giving away a
little bit less at the door this year
yeah yeah we are it's unfortunate but
you know it's just the the nature of the
world nowadays it's impacting us quite a
bit but we still have to have the candy
for the trick-or-treaters The Young Ones
especially inflation making a trick of
treats and the price of cocoa and sugar
is to blame right now sugar prices are
at a 12year high and so manufacturers
had to pay more for uh to to to produce
the the candies that are going to be
heavily distributed on Halloween this
year but perhaps the scariest part about
Halloween this year is that after you
pay more you get less as these small
bits of chocolate get even smaller they
try to disguise as the prices go up they
don't want people to be as aware of it
as you know as we are I remember when as
a kid that they were a lot bigger and um
I know the kids are disappointed at how
small they
are what's become known as shrink
flation isn't unique to Halloween treats
but it's a lot easier to spot since the
funsize candy isn't always on store
shelves we do believe that many candies
have actually been reduced by at least
10% if not
more even after Halloween there are more
scary days ahead with both cocoa and
sugar prices expected to rise meaning
the cost of Candy by
Christmas could be the biggest fright of
all Heather urix West Global News
Calgary and that is global national for
this Tuesday I'm Donna freezen in
keeping with the Halloween spirit here
are a couple of our viewers pets who
let's face it have no real choice in the
matter but do do look super cute I doubt
those costumes stay on for very long
thanks for watching hope you have a fun
and safe Halloween
[Music]
bye-bye